doublelift has never had the most
harmonious of relationships with the
owner of one of his former teams tsm's
reginald for the past six years the two
have had a pretty complicated
relationship both professionally and
personally but last week things got
nasty what started out as a bit of a
pointed exchange of words boiled over
into accusations of emotional abuse
bullying and driving some players to
tears
all right i'd say if anything can be
called drama in this world it's stories
like this and if you don't want to miss
stories like this then make sure you are
subscribed to the channel also leave the
video a like if you feel like doing that
and hit the notification bell all good
stuff doublelift along with former tsm
teammate bjergsen is the biggest name in
north american league of legends even if
you've never played the game you've
probably heard of him domestically his
career is still unparalleled the guy has
taken home an astounding eight lcs
titles as part of three different teams
he's done it with clg team liquid and
team solomid after leaving team liquid
in 2020 doublelift returned to tsm to
help them win the summer split after a
fairytale run through the losers bracket
when tsm went to worlds though things
went disastrously wrong as the team
failed to win a single game and crashed
out of the tournament with a zero six
record
i can reset we can make it we can make
it
oh i can't make it i can't come here
i can make it
one shot
i'm fine i'm fine
okay nidalee nidalee nidalee oh
[ __ ]
soon after the dane in the mid lane
bjergsen announced his retirement and
stepped into the role of tsm's head
coach he has since announced that he's
coming out of retirement to play again
though but not for tsm although
initially looked like doublelift
wouldn't be joining bjergsen in
retirement a month later he announced
that he in fact would be in his post
titled reflections doublelift reminisced
about his experiences throughout his
decade plus time in the scene and asked
fans to support him during his next
chapter in february 2021 doublelift
expanded on his reasons for retirement
basically sum it up quickly i just
didn't feel like competing anymore i
mean competing was something that i
loved doing for for 10 whole years
but um i think i reached a point in my
career where first it was expected of me
to win lcs and anything below winning
lcs would basically be considered a
failure right it would be considered a
step down because i'd been winning so
much and i every single year that i came
in i felt really really good about it i
felt like my my you know this is a team
i really believed in this environment i
really believed in
but when swarm retired i really didn't
feel that same level of of confidence
that i normally do and that's like kind
of like strike one it's like oh well you
know it's like my one of my closest
friends one of one of the best players
in the entire league that uh i basically
joined tsm to play with
is retiring that obviously weighed on me
a lot he also said there was nothing
left for him to do in his career except
try and make out groups of worlds which
was an unfulfilling goal for him that
the goal of winning worlds seemed
unrealistic because the gap between the
east and the west had widened and of the
lack of live audiences because of the
pandemic kind of sucked but that wasn't
the whole story far from it in fact the
day after doublelift announced his
retirement tsm announced they were
signing veteran support and recent
worlds finalist sword art from chinese
powerhouse sooning on a two-year deal
for a record-breaking three million
dollars a year and because of this a lot
of people found the timing of doublelift
leaving a little bit confusing i mean
sure he had his reasons for retiring but
he was a chance to play with a
world-class support that could truly
elevate his game why would he walk away
from that yeah basically what happened
is
we were in the middle of off season
i was thinking about
am i going to keep playing and if i i
think i did initially want to play just
with the best possible roster that i
could
and
i was really excited for the whole sword
art thing
uh
they told me that sword i was confirmed
and i got really excited
and then i guess the negotiations were
going really bad
at a certain point
so then they told me actually it fell
through
it's not going to work would you still
be committed if your support was pallet
since the beginning i'd i'd wanted to
play with somebody who spoke english
which is why sword art was like so
[ __ ] hot because he actually speaks
great english for an import and i want i
always want to play somebody that i can
communicate with because balling is so
important that you can be on the same
page
and that you can talk through things
uh i did not want to play with someone
who
i couldn't talk to
so at the time there was a hint of
animosity doublelift said that tsm
didn't like him saying that he wouldn't
play with pallets but by and large it
seems they parted amicably that's why it
was such a shock that last week almost a
year after he left the team he dropped
this bombshell on stream and for those
of you who don't know tsm reginald's
real name is andy honestly i [ __ ]
hate dsm because
mostly because of andy
i actually remember this now yeah sword
art called me afterwards and said i'm
coming to tsm are you sure like he still
want to play with me and then
uh
i called andy and told him yeah sword
still wants to play with me um
and i would love to you know continue to
play for the org and andy literally said
no because he's got too much of an ego
so here he's saying that after he left
and sword art joined sword art called
him to try and get him to play with tsm
again because he wanted to play with
doublelift and according to doublelift
reggie wasn't having any of it and
rejected his proposal to rejoin the team
and for anyone thinking that doublelift
saying he hated tsm was just a slip of
the tongue he doubled down on his
feelings soon after i went and i got hot
pot with sword art
and i think it was between spring and
summer split it was around msi and the
dude was literally saying that if me and
bjergsen were still playing we would
have 100 won it's like
just unbelievable decisions i don't know
every split i'm on tsm we win and still
like
get treated like that it's just
disgusting it would be a personal
pleasure of mine to never to see tsm
never win anything again
because of how how shitty they treated
the people who who brought them
everything i mean [ __ ] just blew up from
there here was doublelift the trash
talking veteran long time face of the
lcs publicly stating that he hates one
of the biggest esports orgs around and
not just any orc but one of the ones
that he played with for many splits over
the years who he'd won his last lcs
trophy with and at the time of recording
it's also the org where his girlfriend
is president of esports although there
are rumors of her leaving which some
think is why doublelift has decided to
pull the trigger on all of this now now
some of you might already know that but
for those of you that didn't it gets
even messier than that because lena is
also the ex-girlfriend of tsm's owner
reggie now when it comes to this love
work triangle there have been
accusations in the past of a potential
conflict of interest most notably when
doublelift played for team liquid on the
tsm discord she said the whole thing
blew up because of an argument saying so
like logically both sides make sense but
keep in mind this is over the course of
24 hours not the he doublelift was given
time to think on it or andy was given
time to work on the sword art deal he
was told saudar isn't happening not that
the deal was going bad that he asked to
explore his options and he said you have
to commit or we will find an a.d carry
that will peter said no lena's
intermediary tone continued when stating
that the real truth is two dudes who
have impossible egos to deal with it's
not reggie's side or peter's side and
the dust barely had a chance to settle
before reggie himself replied to the
whole situation on the tsm subreddit in
a post titled thoughts on doublelift it
was a direct rebuttal to what doublelift
had said on stream the timelines of what
happened were by and large quite similar
but the interpretations were miles apart
reggie said that doublelift told him he
wouldn't be as motivated if they got a
non-english speaking support for him
such as pallet and that quote it's
extremely discouraging for both staff
and players to work with someone who is
constantly ambivalent about whether he
wants to play or retire he also went on
to say that it wasn't solely his
decision to replace doublelift and that
it was a group decision it was in the
final section where reggie talked about
this year though that things really took
a turn he said i'm assuming that he's
upset because we weren't interested in
working with him he was exploring his
options and we were not interested in
working with him for these reasons he's
always changing his mind on whether he
wants to play or retire his teammates
coaches don't like working with him if
he doesn't like you or doesn't agree
with your decision making he flames you
publicly the ball had been hit back over
the net when doublelift got on stream
the next day he clapped back at reggie's
post and all this happened by the way
it's just like all blew up at once it's
like okay
and he calls me he's like yo are you
committed to the roster even if uh it's
total [ __ ] if it's palafox or like our
backup korean mid laners and palette and
like we don't have a top laner and he
put me on the spot and i was like
no i i don't think i would work well in
that environment honestly like
i
i don't feel good about it
um
and then he's like okay well okay then
uh you don't have a spot on a team
anymore but all of the sword art stuff
took a back seat as doublelift really
started to open up on reggie as an owner
and as a person he said that he
shouldn't have initially said that he
hated tsm because those accusations were
mainly aimed at reggie and when he spoke
this time things got a lot more personal
people don't like working with them it's
funny that he has his whole reason now
attitude about it because
he's like a bully who gets away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what i'm sick of
that when i was talking to my friends
last night on discord that's what i
realized
is that like
i'm sick of somebody who's basically
just a bully
getting away with it because it's in
everyone's best interests and not
getting in his way in fact doublelift
said that reggie's verbal abuse of
players was enough to trigger mental
breakdowns in some of them he made
so many players cry i don't want to name
them actually because
i feel like it's it's not my story to
tell
so i would just say that he made a lot
of players cry you would be very [ __ ]
surprised
at how many of maybe your your favorite
familiar faces in lcs
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they're just getting verbally assaulted
this was on a whole other level it's one
thing to say that you didn't like how
your old boss handled off-season
signings it's another thing to accuse
them of verbally abusing their employees
to the point of tears now doublelift
didn't name any players in particular
but some did speculate as to who he was
referring to there was a clip from 2013
circulating of an argument between
former tsm top laner dyrus and reggie in
which dyrus lost his call with his
former boss
i'm sorry
[Applause]
tweeted out this past week saying i
can't speak for the people after i
retired but nobody got abused during my
time we all grieved each other he went
on to call out doublelift saying don't
downplay what my old teammates coaches
whoever said involved during my era if
you are a victim then by all means say
whatever you want don't hold it in go
for it but i refuse to believe someone
like doublelift is a victim to this
another example was x special videos of
the former tsm support in heated
exchanges including a clip of him crying
have been used to demonstrate reggie's
alleged toxic behavior
are you arguing just to argue with me no
it feels like like you're just trying to
put it all in turtle no i'm not putting
it on turtle no you are putting it all
in turtle
okay
oh yeah you are yeah yeah
okay yeah i i know that but so just say
why are you arguing with me about it
it's so true though like you're the best
led you at your school that's why you
went to all summer
it's really obvious
it's really obvious but
people need to do what they're really
good at and
my mechanics aren't that good i'm really
good at shot calling and that's why i
specialize in and when when someone
when someone tells me like
their judgment is better than mine in
i can't i can't play well because that's
what i'm spending most of my time but x
special tweeted out that he's still
friends with reggie and the people's
analysis of eight-year-old videos is
ridiculous other former players such as
wild turtle and the odd one echoed
similar sentiments but there were others
who backed doublelift former tsm coach
woodbuck said that six years on from his
time at tsm he still gets irrationally
upset about working with reggie and that
it was the most toxic environment he'd
ever been a part of so after the
original drama the reply the reply to
the reply and everyone else weighing in
where are we now well it's important to
split the whole thing into two parts
here first we've got the whole
doublelift retiring and sword art
joining story bretty said the team
didn't want doublelift back because he
was too flip-floppy doublelift said that
sawdart did want to play with him but
reggie's ego stopped that from happening
to be honest it sounds like a fairly
typical esports bus stop not the highest
stakes involved but what happened after
certainly is doublelift's accusations of
reggie being a bully who drove his
players to tears has already sent
ripples around the league community if
the allegations are true and are later
backed up by the alleged victims it
could have huge repercussions for reggie
and tsm as an orc from an employment and
recruitment standpoint like a lot of
things to do with tsm over the years the
whole thing has divided opinion there
are those who say that doublelift is
breaking his silence against a
tyrannical lcs owner there are those who
are taking the accusations with a pinch
of salt and point to the testimony of
former tsm players who defend reggie or
at the very least don't see eye to eye
with doublelift's perspective and in
fact this is also something that
outraged doublelift on twitter he said
reading people's anecdotes that andy was
nice to them and thus downplay the fact
that he harassed and abused people at
tsm as their boss is just so disgusting
no wonder people don't feel good about
speaking up about their abusers reggie
has not responded since doublelift's
rebuttal to his reddit post for now the
allegations remain unanswered and the
story incomplete it's unlikely that it
all ends here though will the players
who are the alleged victims come forward
and share their stories now is reggie
preparing another reply and if
everything that's happened so far has
been so public what could possibly be
going on right now behind the scenes
[Music]
[Music]